there are these two basic fundamental
fears these or fears that are rippling
through our societies the first is the
fear of complexity and the second is the
fear of change I think that if you start
with the question of the fear of change
the first thing of course you have to
note is that a hundred years ago I was a
little more than a hundred years ago
Henry Henry Adams the American writer
wrote about what he called the
acceleration of history but history has
never had been accelerating as quickly
as speedily as it is now it is an
absolutely dizzying it leads to a kind
of experience of mass vertigo and I
think this fear of complexity and this
fear of change has led many people in
the West to seek comfort and refuge and
asylum in a variety of fake or dangerous
solutions the first one I think of I
would call the over socialization of our
idea of the person that is to say the
individual is now commonly reduced to
his or her membership in a group so that
an individual is regarded mainly
primarily and most gloriously as a
representative of a group and the
dignity of the individual now is
increasingly owed to his or her
belonging to his or her belonging as if
belonging is the very highest to which
human beings can aspire instead what one
has to do is get beyond one's one's
bubble once trapped one's origins and
recognize that not only do we need to
speak across the differences but in fact
we speak across the differences all the
time it's a complete ideological hoax
that people really are trapped in
they're in it in their bubble in the in
the partiality of their perspectives and
so for these two larger reasons I would
say that the single most prominent and
alarming development of our time is a
kind of global Renaissance
of illiberal ISM I would say building on
what Leon said about the groups and and
the proliferation proliferation of
groups that I that consider themselves
based on identity even more so than
shared beliefs that that's coupled with
another very dangerous component of
modernity which is technology and the
splintering of media so that when you
had Thomas Monde who came to America and
you had tens of thousands of people who
would come out to see him the promise of
Technology and of mass communications
was this idea that if someone came at
that level to speak that they would be
able to reach this mass audience whereas
the opposite is true today because
instead what's happened is that the
media and with the Internet in
particular everything has become siloed
so dramatically that each group is
speaking only to itself and so that
there's there is no exchange of ideas
and then to go back to what Leon said
about fear and anger there is now a fear
of ever speaking outside of your
identity group and across those various
siloed interests and then incredible
anger at anyone who dares to do that to
transgress in that way yeah I mean I
would I would maybe add I don't know if
it's the right word but one of the
thicknesses is also occasioned by by
this fear is the disconnection
disconnection with others because we
have even though you know it's with
technology and with the internet you
have the we have the feeling that we are
more and more connected to each other I
think it's the complete opposite that is
happening we have we are disconnected
from other people exactly for that same
reason that you that you talked about
which is we have we have divided
ourselves in groups we have divided
ourselves in in groups and parties and
religions in countries we have built
walls we have built gates we have
passports that identify us from each
other so it's there's this fear of this
difference of this other I think you
know we have many other problems to
contend with that worry us primarily
problems to do with justice problems to
do with the economic situation
distribution of wealth problems to do
with poverty throughout the world and I
think these are basic problems and these
are problems that are developing and one
has to ask the question about Europe in
this context in those in those terms in
the terms of you know
well Europe sounds in its in itself or
for itself like a wonderful place and
maybe people are inside of it happy or
not happy but the question is and the
United States as well maybe but then
what about the rest of the world and I
think the main from my point of view a
problem that Europe has is that probably
it does not see and interact with the
rest of the world even on the basis of
the values that it you know professes
itself to have liberal values for
instance a quality and so on and so
forth and I think that is a very
important problem for Europe as I see it
from the Middle East
you